- [Mark] Okay, Elizabeth,
where'd you grow up,
where are you from originally?
- [Elizabeth] Originally, I'm from Ohio
and I was raised here in Clarksburg.
- [Mark] Clarksburg, West Virginia?
- [Elizabeth] Mm-hm.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- Well, my mom and my dad,
but my dad was in and out basically.
- [Mark] When you say
your dad was in and out,
meaning he was...
- He ended up getting put in jail
and so my mom had us for most of the time.
And he tried to push
himself back in our life,
but we didn't really
understand why he left
in the first place, so we
didn't really want anything
to do with him.
- [Mark] And how was life with your mom?
- It wasn't really life, it was...
It sucked, it really did.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff was going on?
- My mom, she was hooked
on coke really bad
and her and her boyfriend,
they started selling it
and everything and I got involved with it,
so young I started using.
- [Mark] At what age did you start?
- 12.
- [Mark] 12, did you finish high school?
- No.
- [Mark] No, how far
did you get in school?
- 10th.
- [Mark] 10th grade?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And where'd you go
after you left your mom's house?
- I got put in...
I've been in and out of
foster home and placements
and stuff like that.
I got taken from her.
- [Mark] Oh, at what age?
- Well, the first time,
I think I was eight
and I got put in a foster home.
And then my dad got me out,
and then that's when he dropped
me off here in Clarksburg.
- [Mark] What do you
mean he dropped you off?
- He ended up going to
jail for credit card theft,
but he didn't tell anybody
he was going to jail.
He just dropped us off at
Thanksgiving to my mom.
- [Mark] So then what happened from there?
- From there...
It's foggy, but she
just didn't really care.
She didn't know how to raise us.
She wasn't a good mom.
But her boyfriend, well,
I grew up, he's my dad.
I seen him as my dad and he
ended up turning into somebody
that I didn't even know.
- [Mark] Any abuse or anything like that?
- Yeah, well, not when I was young,
but when I got older, yeah.
My mom knew about it,
she let me go over there
and stuff like that and
yeah, stuff happened.
- [Mark] Sexual abuse?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you left home at what age?
So you were in the foster system,
but you were going back and forth to home?
- Yeah, well, yeah.
And when I was staying with
my mom, I ended up getting put
in placement for truancy.
And then I got out of placement
and just kept going back and
forth and some stuff happened
with more sexual abuse
and I had to go testify
and my mom lied on the stand.
And somebody else, the
state let them take me in
and they ended up kicking me out
and I got put back in placement.
- [Mark] And so today you're living where?
- Everywhere.
- [Mark] You're just drifting?
- Mm-hm.
- [Mark] Are you using drugs as well?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Which is your drug?
- Meth, I'm an IV user.
- [Mark] And what do you do for money now?
- I tried the middleman stuff
and sell to other people
and I wouldn't call it prostituting,
but I more or less, men.
I basically flirt with
men, finesse them and stuff
and help me, but that's the
only people who wanna help me
seems like are men.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And do you have kids of your own?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How many kids do you have?
- I have two little girls.
- [Mark] And you're
raising your daughters?
- No.
- [Mark] Where are they?
- Both of them are in the foster family.
- [Mark] Do you have any
contact with them at all?
- No.
- [Mark] No.
So do you have any friends
here in the street,
do have anyone you trust
or anyone you're close to?
- No, not...
No, definitely not.
There are this couple,
they've helped me out a lot.
They're a big part of my life,
but they basically sell drugs, too,
so still the dope game,
you can't trust nobody.
- [Mark] Yeah, you been arrested before?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] For drugs?
- No, for a domestic and trespassing.
- [Mark] What are the
biggest problems or dangers
that you have with your lifestyle?
- Being a 24-year-old woman
on the streets, it's tough.
Most of the problem is men
and people think they
can take advantage of you
because you're a female and you're young.
- [Mark] What's the worse
thing that's happened to you?
- I've had somebody hotshot me.
I had them work up my shot down at GoMart,
and next thing you know
I ended up doing it,
I woke up with my pants down
and I was laying right beside GoMart.
- [Mark] I'm sorry, somebody shot you?
- Yeah, I had them work up my shot
and they basically put heroin
and meth in it together
and hotshotted me out of it.
- [Mark] Oh, a hotshot.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- [Mark] Have you OD'd before?
- Yeah, three times, yeah.
- [Mark] Where do you see
your life going from here?
You're 24 and what do you see happening
in the next five, 10 years?
- I don't see anything happening.
I don't know what my future is.
I want better, I've tried to do better
but the streets just
keep coming back to it.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's almost
like you're addicted to this.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, do you see the connection
between what happened to you as a kid
and where you are today?
- [Elizabeth] Yeah, 'cause
if honestly it wasn't for all
of this happening, I wouldn't
become the person I am today
and probably a lot worse
if everything that happened this way.
I could be dead or something else.
- [Mark] Do you get depressed?
- [Elizabeth] Oh yeah.
- [Mark] You been suicidal before?
- [Elizabeth] Yeah.
- [Mark] You have.
What kind of stuff have you considered?
- [Elizabeth] Well, I had to
get my stomach pumped once
for I took a whole bottle
of my seizure medication
when I was younger.
My mom watched me grab the
bottle out of her cabinet.
And she asked me what I
was doing and I told her
and she started cussing me and everything.
And I went in the bedroom
and I just walked in
and from there, it's blank.
I woke up three days
later in the hospital.
- [Mark] Have you considered
getting a therapist
and talking this stuff out?
- [Elizabeth] I've had
therapists all my life.
I don't see talking to somebody
who hasn't been through
what I've been through
helpful at all.
I feel like they're judging me.
- [Mark] When was the
worst point of your life?
- Now.
- [Mark] Right now?
- I'd rather relive
everything I did as a child,
it's bad to say, than do
what I'm going through now.
- [Mark] But if you had
two parents that loved you
and supported you and all that,
you feel like you'd be
in a different space?
- If I had two totally
different parents, yeah.
- [Mark] And in some ways,
it's almost like you're
repeating the cycle.
- Oh yeah, every day I wake up,
I wonder where I'm gonna lay my head,
how I'm gonna get money to feed myself.
There's days I go without
eating, not because I'm on meth
but because I can't afford to eat.
- [Mark] Yeah.
You ever been in love before?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Does this lifestyle
get in the way of that?
- Well, me being homeless
and not really having anything, yeah.
- [Mark] What do you think
would help you the most right now?
- If someone could just
help me and not doubt me.
People doubting me is the
worst 'cause it gives me
in my head to where I feel like I can't,
but I know I can do better.
'Cause I don't see a point
in trying to get better
and trying if I don't really
have anything to live for.
- [Mark] Yeah, losing your kids
has gotta set you back, right?
Is that what gets to you the most?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's gotta be hard.
And then your unstable housing
has gotta be difficult to deal with, too.
- If I had my own place, I
definitely wouldn't be like this.
I mean, I just wanna be able to...
I don't even know the
last time I laid in a bed.
- [Mark] Where do you typically sleep,
or with crystal meth, you don't sleep?
- Well, I mean, eventually
you have to sleep,
yeah, but I do.
I just usually a guy's
house I have to stay at
and I'm too scared to fall asleep.
But when my parents,
they're not my real parents,
but they're my street parents,
they have their own life to live, too.
I can't go there and sleep whenever.
- [Mark] Do you have
any dreams or anything
that you'd love to see happen for yourself
or are you just trying to survive?
- Both, I mean, I just want to be able
to have something of my own.
I wanna be able to say
I accomplished something
and something good, instead of...
But yeah, I'm just trying to survive.
- [Mark] Yeah, and there's
a lot of shame in this.
You feel guilty for losing
your kids, you feel guilty
for some of the things you do.
- Yeah, yeah.
I should've known the way
I grew up with my mom.
As soon as I had my kid,
I was like, yeah, I know what to do,
I know how to raise her and everything.
And I didn't.
- [Mark] What do you think it is?
Do you think it's just that
your self worth gets set
at a low point because of what
you went through as a kid,
having the mom you did, having a stepdad
that did what he did?
- In a way, it makes me
stronger, but with all my...
I have a lot of mental issues
and that gets in the way.
That got in the way of me being
a mother and everyday life.
- [Mark] What's the hardest part for you?
- [Elizabeth] Being alone,
knowing that there's nobody
that really cares, nobody.
- [Mark] All right,
Elizabeth, thank you so much
for talking with me and I wish you luck
getting your life together.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You could use
some nice breaks, right?
Thank you.